vous travailler 15 heures par jour vous
avez six secrétaires et les six
chauffeurs mais non non combien de
chauffeur un chauffeur avoué qu'enfant
pas c'est bien la peine de nous tous mal
les cinq se placer avec quand même vous
avez des [ __ ] non non non d'amener dans
tout bon moment bah oui je suis méfiant
des vieux jeux quand même vous possédez
quoi au juste
une danse maison bonne santé c'est
apparemment un jimmy webb atouts
principaux meilleur valais fait
d'accepter des invitations comme la
vôtre à illange mentir vas toujours et
on vous dit je me retirerai toujours
vous parler des filles du public
vous avez des actions en bourse
non mais débouche en action c'est un
moteur d'actifs la non mais j'en ai eu
puis bon bah j'ai compris que la
spéculation qui n'était pas intellectuel
n'était pas mon fémur
on sait mais beaucoup plénier tudiants
de payer trop d'impôts en fait vous
payez pas comme les gentils gagnent
comme vous finalement non je me suis
jamais plaint de payer trop d'impôts je
me suis plaint que l'on soit pas gentil
avec moi quand je les paye et je le paye
toujours à l'heure et au jour dit depuis
longtemps et 2 qu' on emploie mon argent
plus mal que je ne le ferai
ouais vous plaignez quand c'est la
droite au pouvoir c'est la gauche au
pouvoir donc finalement votera oui alors
j'ai jamais dit ça y est je sais que je
ne serai jamais remettre louis avec la
gauche ni avec chaleur et le centre
n'existant plus râleurs touche peut être
vous serez fer en ses moyens mais
charasse vous a pas collé un contrôle
fiscal pour vous calmer pas non non non
on change de ces rigolos
vous étiez plutôt chirac jusqu'à ce que
vous rencontriez mitterrand et vous
parliez de jules renard et de flaubert
avec lui et ça vous a fait changer
d'avis l'aifa prof de lettres non non
mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu des
conversations littéraire du à fait
passionnante
avec monsieur françois mitterrand mais
c'est indépendant de toute politique on
peut avoir de la sympathie pour un homme
vous avez 62 ans oui pourquoi continuer
ma ba oui pourquoi m'a peut-être à cause
de celui dont vous avez cité le nom
accolé jaras s'il apprécie comprendrait
pas que je m'arrête vous dites toujours
je fuis quelque chose mais au fond c'est
plus nous fuit et maintenant si je fuis
le chômage en travailleurs maintenant
vous avez laissé tomber le poker j'ai
moins besoin d'argent quand même ah oui
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins c'est
beaucoup des choses très classe ça me
coûte c'est très chaud je perdais mon
argent
mon temps mes nerfs mais nuit et mes
amis qui devenaient des clients alors
vous verrez que c'est vrai que vous
étiez fait interdire en france et vous
alliez jouer à l'étranger séditieuse sa
grand mère alors ça vous coûte encore
plus cher parce que y'a le voyage